ladies and gentlemen this emergency
session is called to order
Admiral mission you have the floor
200 years
we have buried the mandrill
we have caught these attacks rains or
skirmishes our incursions but I am here
to tell you that we are at war
type Oh Ryan Caliban burnt once human
systems are but abandoned in the face of
the enemy
the man duel her gaze weapon spared
while we we hide coward
retreating as they burn and decimate
everything around us
we cannot let the tragedy of Vega happen
again we cannot give the van Gogh any
more ground
to define the sample we must attack and
we have to be committed to that attack
whatever the cost may be
we have to rebuild our fleet
we have to use the power of human
innovation to reclaim these so-called
red systems and strike back at the enemy
those will not be an easy fight it will
cost us
resources new credits relies
when some of you may be asking why
undertake such a thing and I I can tell
you in one word
victory
if this one thing the bangles taught us
it's not without victory there can be no
survival
you
you